hello 大家好 欢迎收听好果将radio 我是莫莫。
前一阵北京已经悄悄的进入了夏天。
有几天的气味已经到了37、38度，真的热得非常夸张。
正好公司有一个团建的机会，
我就前后凑了几天个人的假期去了一趟贵州。
主要是在安顺附近徒步攀岩，
然后吃了很多当地的美食。
也遇到了一些我觉得非常真诚善良有意思的人。
想起来去年夏天，我好像也是去了一趟贵州。
主要是去了前东南的一些少数民族的寨子，
好像还没有和大家分享过。
所以就想趁这次一起和大家聊一聊贵州到底有什么好玩的。
当然贵州整个省非常非常的大，
还有很多我想去但是还没来得及去的地方。
所以如果你之前在贵州有什么有意思的旅行故事，
或者你本身就是来自贵州的朋友，
也欢迎大家在评论区留言分享你之前的旅行经历。
这期播客就是一期我自己的非常不完整的贵州旅行日记。
正好夏天就要到了。
如果你有计划去到贵州避暑的话，
希望这期内容对你有所帮助，
也提前祝大家收听愉快。
首先我想先说一下对整个贵州的印象。
就像这期播客标题说的，
就是好山好水好吃好玩，
就只有景区不行，
就是真的很不行。
整个贵州其实有不少的5A级景区，
因为那边真的风景比较独特，
有很多特别的地贸特征。
但是我觉得国内大部分的5A级景区都是非常值得一去的。
虽然各个地方的旅行体验可能不近相同，
会有这样那样的问题，
但是风景绝对都是世界一流的。
所以我在两次贵州的旅行都给自己安排了一个当地的5A级景区。
去年是前东南的千户苗寨，
这次是安顺附近的直津洞。
同时两次也都搭配了一些这些5A级景区附近的，
几乎免费的那种野生的景点。
那千户苗寨搭配的就是一个附近还没有什么商业开发痕迹的小众苗寨。
直津洞搭配的就是安顺附近的几个野生的徒步和攀岩的地点。
我只能说相比之下，
这些野生景点的体验还有性价比真的就是无敌。
这些官方景点我觉得风景本身的问题不大，
但是风景之外其他的体验就真的有太多值得吐槽的地方了。
所以接下来就是一段我的吐槽，
我也想先声明这个也是基于我个人的一些体验和我个人的喜好。
贵州还有很多非常原生态我很喜欢的地方后面会聊到，
也欢迎大家在评论区补充你的故事。
我们先来说第一个5A级景点就是千户苗寨。
这个我想是很多人从小到大就一直听说的地方，
不管是小学的语文课本、中学的地理课本可能都有提到过它。
那现在想说说你去搜贵州旅行，
它一定也会被推荐的，
而且你会看到很多非常好看的照片，
不管是风景照、人像照都有。
但是我去完之后几乎唯一的感受就是后悔。
就是它的景色是好看的，但是就是太商业化了。
你走进去整个街边全部都是旅拍店还有纪念品商店，
而且纪念品商店卖的东西都是大同小异，
就是你能想象到的那些我在千户苗寨很想你的冰箱贴之类的，
然后大部分的东西如果你用淘宝试图都能找到更低价格，
可以包邮送到家的同款。
然后旅拍店就更夸张了，
它会展示很多少数民族的服饰。
虽然看起来确实是非常的出偏很有当地特色，
但是你摸起来那个质感就是非常素料，
早就不是人家当地少数民族用的那种不知的工艺了，
就是普通的泥笼布料，
而且经常还会出现那种跨民族的服饰大乱顿，
因为整个苗族其实是一个非常庞大的民族，
有上百个知系。
西江千户苗寨属于前东南的一个知系，
它比较有特色的东西是牛角银帽、银罐、银巷圈，
还有特别有特色的白者群。
但是很多旅拍店摆出来的服饰，
根本就不是当地的苗族服饰，
可能有湘西的苗族、有云南的苗族，
甚至你还能看到一些我觉得是文古族或者藏族的服饰。
然后有时候他们也会把一些新娘的银式啊，
为婚少女的银式啊，还有其他的一些头饰混搭在一起。
就是你穿在身上可能真的觉得很出偏，
但是对我来说我可能还是更希望能够接触到那种真正的当地的服饰还有风土人情。
而且很多人可能想说去千户苗寨可以看看建筑什么的，
但是我真的进到这个景区就发现，
首先原本住在这些村寨里面的村民早就已经不住在这里了。
而且大部分的建筑都被用作酒店之类的商业用途，
传统的那种损帽结构的吊脚楼已经几乎不见了。
现在你看到的都是外表式木头，
但其实里面是那种钢筋混凝土结构的那种半吊子现代建筑。
你会觉得有点可惜吧？
而且整个景区非常非常的大，交通也很不方便，
私家车是不能开进去的，
但是景区里面配套的交通还有道路其实对于游客来说并不是非常的友好。
我那次是背着包去的，所以感觉还可以。
但是我经常会路过看到很多那种在石板路上拖着行李箱的游客，
就感觉还是挺痛苦的。
总之我在那里大概呆了一天一夜的时间，
在离开这个景区的时候我心里完全没有一点点的不舍，
就只有无尽的轻松。
我是不是很懂，就是这样的一个景区怎么能凭到5A级。
我不知道国家对于这种景区的评级，
是不是有这种重新评定和审核的机制。
我感觉这个景区对我来说可能去掉一个A，
或者两个A都是非常合理的。
在离开千户苗寨之后呢，
我正好有一个朋友在当地学做这个苗银，
然后在那边已经履居了非常长时间。
他就给我推荐了一个千户苗寨附近的叫做朗德上寨，
他说那里比较的原生态，
我去了之后真的就觉得赞美。
他就是我想象中的那种会去到少数民族债子里面的感觉。
首先在进入债子之前，
你会看到一片绿油油的稻田，
真的还有人拖着牛在那里种地。
然后我去的那天游客其实挺少的，
你在街上遇到的大部分人都是当地的居民，
就是这个债子里面还有很多很多的人是真的住在这个债子里面，
在这里生活的。
然后偶尔你会碰到一些面向游客的店铺，
我就随便走进了一家富士店，
里面都是这个女主人在周围村子里面收集来的那种苗秀的老布片，
然后还有他自己正在秀的这个苗秀的腰带之类的。
就是你一摸你就能感觉出来是人家付出了心血，
老老实实做出来的东西。
然后这个店里也有苗族的俯视可以足给你拍照，
然后我当时摸了一下就觉得好像是那种传统俯视的质感，
然后我就租了一套来拍照。
这个店家姐姐就一边给我打扮一边给我介绍这个是他们过什么节的时候穿的东西，
然后这一套是没有结婚的少女会穿的衣服，
然后你可以通过他们的头发头饰怎么去判断这个女孩子是结婚还是没有结婚之类之类的。
这个才是我期待中的这种苗族俯视拍照的体验吧。
然后后面我出去拍了一圈照觉得外面很热，
然后回来之后这个大姐就跟我说这两年不知道为什么整个贵州的夏天其实也变得很热，
他们小时候不管什么时间穿这种传统俯视虽然确实是里三层外三层有很多布料，
然后也要顶着那种很重的唇印头饰，
但几乎不会觉得很热，
但是这两年夏天最热的时候他自己穿着这些传统俯视也会有一点受不了，
然后这两个债子体验下来我就觉得没有对比就没有伤害，
对比之下我觉得眼前的大姐真的太可爱了。
然后他还和我说其实他们这个债子暑假的时候是有表演的，
是村之书为了发展他们这个债子的旅游在暑假期间会让村民每天好像是11点去债子的中心广场一起唱歌，
然后对于他们唱的歌也没有什么特别的要求，
就是他们平时过节怎么唱怎么跳舞就怎么演就好了。
然后我觉得这样就很好啊，发展旅游和景区不太应该打乱人家当地人原本的生活，
很多时候可能当地人觉得在短时间之内可以通过一些买纪念品啊，
很多商业化的行为获得一些利益赚到一些钱，
比他们本身去种地去生活赚到更多工作的钱。
但是像苗寨这样的地方他本身最珍贵的就是他那份时间沉淀下来的很特别的生活方式，
村民有的时候可能没什么感觉，因为他们一直都生活在这样的生活里。
但是景区的管理者或者说村之书或者说政府，
我真的觉得应该好好地保护这份非常难得的风土人情，
就对于旅游来说审美真的太重要了。
好了吐槽完这个千户苗寨，
我现在想起来好像今年刚刚去过的知津洞这个五位级景区也没那么差了。
那知津洞是在安顺附近，
它是中国目前发现的规模最大发育最完整的卡斯特汉戎洞。
这个戎洞里面真的是没得说，
就是眼花缭乱，
你看起来就像走进了地下星球另一个世界，
然后里面虽然还是打了很多五颜六色的彩色LED灯，
但是在里面的时候就觉得好像我可以和这些彩色LED灯和解了。
那些粉色紫色的光打到那种白白的光滑的中褥时尚，
我会联想起来的是一连幽梦的感觉，就有点浪漫。
然后还有的地方我就觉得走进了那种西游记腰惊动的片场，
可能这种稀奇古怪的魔幻大光本身和这些稀奇古怪的石头还挺搭配的。
我在shownotes里面放了几张照片，
我觉得就算是现在我在手机里面看起来也，
还是不错的就没有其他的景区打奇怪的LED的感觉那么奇怪和难看。
总之熔洞和石头门还是非常美丽的，但是熔洞之外的地方我就觉得非常难平吧。
那首先这整个景区里面，熔洞外面的地方全部都是大喇叭，
就是有卖饮料的，有卖纪念品商店的，有卖雪糕的，有卖吃的的。
就是你走进这个景区就非常非常的吵。
下面我给大家放一小段让大家感受一下。
再接下来就是这个熔洞里面其实非常的大，
你前前后后就算走得比较快的话可能也要走一个小时的时间，
但是这个景区里面是有不少人在抽烟的。
就景区里面虽然是有禁止吸烟的标识，但是工作人员看到完全是不管的。
然后我试图用眼神和言语去制止也都没有成功，
但是工作人员会非常积极的拉你在几个标志性的景点拍照，
说出动之后会有免费的6寸纪念照可以领。
然后我拍的时候就想说好，那我这140块钱的门票可能也没有百花还是挺值得的。
结果到我出门去领照片的时候我就发现打印出来的照片的相纸确实是有6寸，
但是我的照片在这张相纸上只有大概一寸照片那么大，
剩下的部分就是一些白底黑字的标语，
并且这些工作人员在不断的强调说你可以打印7寸的照片一张是20块钱，
现场可以打印你可以带走。
我当然觉得很无语语，
就是我抱着一整个欣赏美景的非常轻松的心态来玩，
然后到最后这个景区就是在玩我，就是被戏弄了那种感觉，
而且你也没办法投诉，
这个东西它也不是官方包含在了门票里面，
它说就是免费送你的，
那你有什么好抱怨的呢？
有一张一寸的照片不是也很不错吗？
反正就是整个的旅行体验有很多让你觉得很别扭的地方，
但是风景也还是不错的，
那之间洞和之间大峡谷我觉得整个体验还是属于可以忍受的部分，
起码自然风光还是被保护的不错的。
评性而论我还是挺推荐大家去的。
那接下来先放一段音乐，
请大家和我一起平复一下心情，
之后我会和大家分享一些我体验到的免费的野生景点，
都非常非常不错。
好，接下来我将为大家介绍这次我给自己安排的。
人均18块的安顺周边一日游，
我呢是去了桐谷档大盛之沿，
还有万峰顶这三个地方，
这三个地方距离安顺大概都是一个小时车程范围内的，
中午12点出发大概晚上8点多就回到了安顺的市区，
这三个地方之前都是完全不收费的野生景点，
现在也都开始有人收费了，
那基本上就是在一个毕竟之路上立一个桌子，
说要收一个叫做卫生费的东西，
基本上就是一个人几块钱这种，
所以也没有人深究到底是谁收了钱这些钱要用去干嘛。
那这三个地方里面我自己最喜欢的是大盛之沿，
首先就是这个路线终点的山洞加水谈的倒影拍出来，
确实很像孙悟空的脸，就还挺神奇的，
而且去大盛之沿的路也很野，
是那种几乎没有铺装的路段需要手脚并用的，
我就觉得还挺有趣的，
但是我去的时候其实也看到了一些穿着脱鞋和裙子的朋友，
就还是有点担心，
我觉得这个路起码还是需要穿一些最基本的运动装和运动鞋的难度，
之后我应该也会在小巫书发视频vlog，
有计划去玩的朋友可以参考看看那个时候的路况是什么样子的。
我的小巫书账号链接也可以在shownotes里面看到，
我觉得这三个景点里面风景最好的是万峰顶，
而且这条路其实不是很难爬，
这个山峰虽然是在周围的这些山峰里面最高的一座山，
但是单程爬山大概只需要三四十分钟的样子，
然后攀升是300米，
我觉得你到山顶之后的景色绝对是物超所知的，
尤其是落日的时候，
我之前总听人说有一个说法说贵州等百万大山，
然后真的直到我走到这个万峰顶的山顶才明白那个是什么意思，
就是真的像凤凰传奇那种歌唱的，
就是乌蒙山连着山外山，
连着山外山，
然后还连着山外山。
不过这个景点好像现在也慢慢活起来了，
走到山顶的时候发现山顶可能大概有100个人吧，
然后还有各种的小吃摊，水果摊，饮料摊，就还是挺热闹的。
我在生动此里面放了一些在山顶拍到的落日风景，
还有人挨着人的盛况，
感兴趣的朋友也可以点进去看一看。
这三个景点里面相比之下，
我觉得铜骨档其实并没有网上宣传的那么好。
它确实是一个很出偏的地方，
就是它的地形地贸确实很奇特，
就有各种地下暗河，
就是一条河流着流着，
突然你就不知道去哪了，
它就到了地下的一个洞里，
可能突然又在某一个地方冒出来了，
因为它是一个海拔比较低的类似盆地的地方，
所以整片都是绿色的草殿，
上面散落着很多风化了的稀奇古怪的黑色石头。
这确实是我之前没怎么见过的地形地贸，
但是在网上大家经常把它包装成一些什么外星球，
我觉得也没有那么的夸张。
不过我之前看到铜骨档之所以叫做铜骨档，
是因为它在大雨之后这些暗河的水流会激增，
然后水流在下面会撞击这些岩壁石缝，
可能有一些空洞的地方就会发出那种很神奇的声音。
我那天好像是听到了，但是我也不是很确定，
所以如果有朋友之后会去到这的话，
除了看风景，可能耳朵也可以仔细的听听看，
能不能听到这种所谓的神奇的铜骨的声音。
那这三个景点搭配到一起，
这一天的形成我觉得已经是满满当当了，
而且确实需要一点点的体力，
尤其是万峰顶、爬山的部分还是有一点累的。
但我觉得可能平时如果你有运动习惯的话，
也是基本上没有什么问题。
那除了这个户外移至游之外呢，
我还给自己安排了一天在贵州六盘水的野外攀岩的形成。
之前我其实都是在室内玩这种眼管的暴食，
但是听说六盘水是国内的一个攀岩圣地吧，
所以就约了一个教练想体验一下野攀，
这也是我第一次在野外攀岩，
结果真的一下就爱上了。
我不知道是不是因为野外真实的岩壁，
周围其实更加的开阔。
就是我觉得在野外你去爬那种什么18-20多米的难度线，
对我来说几乎没有恐高的问题。
但是在室内就算是那种暴食墙稍微高一点点两三米，
我也会就害怕的要死。
然后再加上野外的岩壁其实没有那些预先设定好的所谓的岩点，
你需要仔细的去观察，然后去摸去探索这个岩壁。
我现在再去回想，去拍眼的那一天，
就是不同线路上面的石头，
会带给我的手指很不一样的触感。
洞穴里面的中乳石是很扎手的，
它很粗糙，很锋利。
但是裸露在外面的岩壁可能因为贵州，
确实雨水比较大，
被雨水冲刷的就还是挺光滑的。
以及真的贴在这个岩壁上面去仔细的看这些石头的纹理和它的材质，
就还是能在你的脑子里留下一些对这些山很不一样的印象的。
这些可能我觉得都是你不亲自上到这些攀岩的线路上去摸一摸，
爬一爬看一看，完全不可能体会到的东西。
那同时我觉得这次在六盘水遇到了这个野攀的教练，
也是一个很有意思的人。
他的名字叫做卡卡。
我他聊天的过程中了解到他之前其实在全国各地做过这种户外领队，
高山土步向导，雪山土步向导之类的，
就是在中国的各个户外圣地都转了一圈之后，
他现在就暂时留在了六盘水带人攀岩。
然后和他聊天完全就是给我打开了另一个世界和另一个视角。
其实大家在攀岩或者是野外攀岩的时候都是轮流替换着去爬的。
所以有很多的时间大家都是在地面上休息。
所以我在休息的时候就随口问了一句他，
攀岩的历史是什么样子的？
平时他可能是一个我觉得不苟严笑的很严肃的人。
但是问了这个问题之后一下子就打开了他的画匣子。
他现在是说，攀岩是从欧美开始的，
从很早很早好像二十世纪六十年代就开始了。
最早大家都是处于慢慢摸索的一个状态，
根本没有什么保护措施，
就是用这种登山的绳子在腰部打一个劫。
但是那个时候的绳子是没有弹性的。
所以一旦你手滑脚滑发生冲坠，
重力加速度，还有一些冲击力，
就都会作用在这个攀岩者的腰上。
所以有很多早期研究户外攀岩的人，
他们会出现什么腰部受伤，
被绳子垒断了肋骨，
甚至有内脏破裂，还有癱瘓的情况都是非常普遍的。
直到可能过了得有十几年的时间，
才有人慢慢发明出来了这种，
现在大家用的有延展性的攀岩的动力绳，
还有这种围绕着大腿和腰间的安全安心的这种做事的安全带。
我听到这些的时候真的就非常的震惊和感慨吧。
就是我好像从来没有想过，
我现在觉得理所当然的这些安全保护措施是怎么来的。
也完全没有想象，其实就是几十年前，
看到这种垂直的岩壁就想要爬上去的人，
到底是抱着一种怎么样的心情，
就想说我想爬到这个山顶，
但是是通过手脚并用的这种滑溜溜的垂直的岩壁爬上去。
然后我就问了AI，
那下面就由我来给大家转述一下，
AI给我的答案，他给了我三个答案。
第一个是为了满足对纯粹身体技术的迷恋。
他说在工业革命的后期，
尤其是英国城市里面的上层阶级和知识分子，
厌倦了机械化和体质化的生活。
他们发现面对一面垂直的墙壁的时候，
你所有的金钱和地位都没用了，
你必须用大脑去计算重心，
用肌肉去死磕掩饰。
这种人与自然最原始的博弈，
给他们带来了极大的解放和精神刺激。
那第二个呢，原起是在德国，
是因为德国的体操运动在野外游了延伸。
就说最开始是在德国的萨克森地区，
最早研究野潘的是一群体操运动员，
然后时间是在1874年前后，
他们觉得在室内练习单双杠非常的枯燥，
于是就跑到野外的沙岩断崖边，
把天然的石头缝当作单杠来抓卧。
也是他们这一群人开始非常系统的研究，
怎么利用反向作用力把身体卡在颜缝里面，
怎么利用核心力量来悬空保持平衡，
最早的攀岩动作的理论，
就慢慢开始从这些人当中蒙崖了。
那第三个原因就是阿尔卑斯热潮后的技术内卷，
19世纪末欧洲的很多大山脉的传统路线，
大家都已经走遍了，比如说波浪峰之类之类。
那后来的这些年轻人为了要证明自己，
他们就去寻找更陡，更绝望，
看起来更不可能爬上去的垂直的岩壁，
然后就去研究神所技术，
研究严实的抓卧方法，
正是他们当时这种对于难度，
对于挑战的渴望，
就让这些人成为了所谓的第一批野攀科学家。
我听了这些故事之后就想说，
所以真的不管是哪个行业，
从古至今人为了对抗无聊的日复一日的生活，
为了挑战前人留下来的所谓的标准和限制，
真的什么都能做得出来。
我在户外的时候，
就真的常常会在两种状态下反复横跳，
就一方面我就会觉得说，
OK，我走完这条路线，
翻过这座山头，爬上这个山顶，
又有什么意义呢？
好像就是毫无意义。
但那一方面，
我又觉得好像人本身活着就是毫无意义的。
但是我在户外能够真正的走好我的每一步，
需要我不停的去观察地形，
看周围的植物，
岩壁，天气，
思考下一步的操作，
这些活动本身，
好像已经让我的时间变得充盈很饱满，
好像就已经足够了。
就突然想起之前不知道在哪听过的一句话，
就是我们human being，人类的意义，
其实就是逼影，
就是活在此刻就已经完全足够了。
后来我又问了卡塔中国攀岩的历史，
他好像也是读了一些书，
研究了一些资料，
他说其实是90年代的时候，
美国人现在广西的洋硕的月亮山，
开辟了中国的第一条野潘路线，
从那之后，洋树就成了几乎是中国野潘唯一的选择。
当时洋树的街上90年代，
就有很多背着绳包的那种欧美攀岩爱好者，
中国的第一批本土的攀岩爱好者，
也是从这里和外国人开始接触学习，
开始进行野外攀岩的。
但同一时期，除了南方之外，
北边的北京白河，
也有一批户外爱好者，
他们一开始可能只是，
比如说阿士潘灯的这种登山徒步的爱好者，
慢慢的开始转向去探索这种自然的掩柄。
但那个时候因为，
北方他没有特别多的专业的信息和知识还有设备，
他们用的都是那种黑铁匠打造的铁钉，
保护装备也是非常简陋的，
但是他们还是在北京白河，
开辟了中国本土的第一个本土延长，
所以还是很值得大家敬佩的。
那卡卡当时其实说了很多中国攀岩县区的名字或者外号吧，
有很多我都记不住了，
但是我唯一记住的一个是一个叫做秋江的人，
他的外号叫做县长。
就是现在你去野外攀岩，
你可以在一些网站上找到各种各样的各个地方的野攀的路线，
然后上面都会标注说这个路线的名字叫什么，
他的开县人是谁。
所以现在对我们这种新手小白来说，
我感觉完全是处于那种前人栽树我成良的状态，
因为野攀最麻烦的其实就是开县，
也就是在岩壁上找到合适的攀爬路线，
并且把一些挂片和保护装备放置在那里。
但是开出一条质量高的好的攀岩陷入其实是很难的，
而且也很危险。
首先你得找到那些质量好的不会松动的石头，
你可能还需要把岩壁上可能松动的碎石、泥土、鸟粪，
还有一些可能伤到人的植物全部都处理干净，
然后这个开县师还要在半空中把自己固定住，
拿着可能有几公斤的那种垫钻在坚硬的石头上凸凸凸凸凸凸，
遭到一个洞，
然后再把那些膨胀螺栓还有挂片固定在这些烟石的洞里面。
那卡卡提到的这个叫做秋江的人呢，
就是全中国乃至全亚洲在自然掩毙开县最多，
也是最疯狂的人之一。
现在在很多地方开县，
比如说你是一个延长的开发者，
你可能都需要支付大概一条线两到三千块钱的费用给这个开县的人，
但是县长也就是这个秋江在开县的时候几乎都是没有收费的，
而且消耗的工具和物资也是靠他自己的收入去买的。
然后后来他开的县越来越多，
越来越有名，
才慢慢有了，
比如说延有会给他种仇，
给他买一些东西，
或者是有品牌赞助之类的。
我感觉他就是现在野攀爱好者自面意义上的开山笔转，
然后我开了聊天的时候就发现，
聊到这些攀岩啊户外啊的故事的时候，
真的就是双眼在泛光。
他的那种热情和相信和对老一辈攀岩人的有一点点崇拜的感觉吧，
我觉得是骗不了人的。
然后我当时就觉得啊，
真的是意外的找到了六盘水最好的一个野攀向导吧。
就虽然他的这个野攀是没有什么教学的部分的，
但是他的保护让人很安心，
然后看到这些故事和他本身的热情，
也让我觉得让整个野攀的活动变得更有生气了一起。
然后呢他还分享了一个六盘水市的八卦，
就是说曾经有一个市委书籍，
是非常支持当地区发展户外旅游的，
然后现在很多六盘水很震撼的户外设施，
比如说什么人工盐币、山地自行车赛道，
还有这种景区的公路，
其实都是在他的任期里面规划或者是完成的。
但是他本人也确实被查到有很严重的贪污受贿的问题，
还有很多他开发的户外项目其实最后都是长期闲置的。
甚至呢还有一个他在六盘水亲自开发的攀岩场地，
他就取评叫做步步高升，
这个现在在网上还可以查到这个延长的信息，
但是最后好像是2024年的时候，
他因为贪污受会被抓进去了，好像判了死刑。
这个世界还是挺黑色幽默的，
真的电视剧可能都不敢这么写吧。
后来呢就是聊了攀岩嘛，
然后我们又聊了很多其他关于中国登山的历史，
然后回来之后也查了一些资料发现，
中国登山攀岩户外的历史还是挺沉重的，
因为早期有很多的设备，还有技术不到位，
所以是有很多的前辈付出了非常惨重的生命身体的代价。
换来了我们现在可能一些山的主权，
还有一些线路的开放等等等等吧。
这期播客我们可能就来不及延伸那么多了，
大家感兴趣的话也可以自己去搜搜看，
但是可能要做一些心理准备，
因为这些故事是有一点点沉重。
然后后来在下山的路上我问他为什么不做户外领队了，
然后他就说首先雪山领队实在是太危险了，
他有两个朋友都相继遇到事故去世了，
而且这些事故可能都不是你人为可以控制的，
所以他觉得太危险就不再做雪山和高山的领队了。
而且反过来看他说现在的户外向导的竞争其实也越来越激烈，
而且大家其实没有做到一个他认为的良性竞争，
基本上都是靠打价格战。
你现在在去进入这个圈子其实很难赚到钱，
之前可能十几年前他带过的景区，
现在他在去的时候也觉得已经被搞得乌烟杖气的了，
就很脏，很多垃圾，有很多不负责任的游客和领队，
他就觉得看到这些场子就让他觉得很失望，有点心累吧。
就不如现在在六盘水攀岩，
每个月赚个几千块钱可以过得舒舒服，
接受要的人也还挺有意思的。
然后就想起之前好像有一个很火的博主的视频，
对比了他几年前和现在去统一条穿西土布路线的场景，
曾经真的就是高山下面有一个又美又清澈的湖，
然后湖边大家都很 chill 的样子，
而现在湖边就是各种各样的垃圾，
零食的包装袋，泡面桶等等等等的，
就看着就真的觉得很难理解也很心痛吧。
在户外，不论你有没有领队，有没有巷岛，有没有岛油，
距离下一个垃圾桶到底有多远，
这个带走垃圾不留下任何痕迹都是最基本的操作。
可能中国的户外运动确实还是处于一个比较初期的阶段，
但是现在确实有越来越多的人愿意走到户外去接触大自然，
去体验他，我觉得这是很好的。
而且可能扔垃圾的很多人也并不是故意为之，
他们就是习惯了平时在景区，在公园那种有巷岛有领队，
有清洁工人会帮你兜底清理的这种旅游模式，
但是可能也希望越来越多的人知道说户外这些土布路线，
其实是没有人有义务去给你做这种垃圾清理和维护的。
而且很多的野生动物和环境真的在被破坏了之后就没有回头路的。
所以我感觉我能做的也不是很多，
就通过我们这个小小的播客呼吁一下，
也希望更多的人能够一点一点的让我们中国的户外运动的环境变得越来越好吧。
同时也希望在那之前我们祖国的这些大美的河山野生的动物，
他们的生活还不会变得太差。
这次在贵州的时候，其实我觉得老天爷还是非常的赏脸的。
就是我在那几天几乎都没有下雨，
我觉得可能像大圣之眼这样的景点，
如果真的遇到下雨的话，那些路会非常的逆宁，真的会蛮危险的。
但是我去的时候就都非常的好。
但是因为我去贵州之前的几天，贵州有下这种大雨，
整个的河水都涨水了，还是有几个我这次很想去的景点没有能去成，
在这里也推荐给大家。
有一个是罗杨河素西，我看了很多的视频和图片，
就是你真的可以在清澈见底的河里去漂流，去游泳，
而且这也是一个野生的景点。
我去之前连领队都找好了，
但最后因为大雨冲刷了很多泥沙到河里面，
所以我在的那几天河水都很浑浊，
就是那种黄色的混了很多泥的像黄河一样的感觉，
就没有那种清澈的体验了。
而且涨水的时间其实在河里面活动也是比较危险的，
所以那个领队就把活动都取消了。
然后另一个我很想去玩也错过了的，
就是安顺周围其实有很多的熔洞，
然后这些熔洞也有那种洞穴探险的体验，
但不知道为什么其实很多到了七月份才会开放，
然后我好不容易搜到了一个曾经的野生熔洞，
就叫做莲花鼓洞，
看起来就是进入没有什么难度，接近性很好，
而且里面也很美，
感觉是那种不需要领队，
你只要下载了比较合适的户外路线，
普通人自己去也可以的那种。
结果这个莲花鼓洞在五一期间，
不知道被哪位大佬承包了下来，
现在已经变成了莲花鼓洞探险公园了。
据说在这个洞里面搞了一堆那种非拉达省匠之类的项目，
单人门票880元。
我真的就是望而却步，
所以最后也没有去。
现在我感觉只能默默许愿，
就是在我下次再去贵州之前，
户外大佬们能探索出来一些新鲜的陷入，
让我这种普通人也能去看一看，
卧国贵州的这些美丽的卡纳斯荣动。
总之我觉得这次在贵州停留的时间还是短了一些，
虽然我在那已经待了六天的时间了，
但是还是有很多东西都没有玩上。
我感觉夏天如果有机会的话，
还可以再去一趟贵州。
同时也提醒大家，
贵州的雨水在夏天确实比较多。
大家如果要去安排行程的话，
确实要多多的注意天气，
而且可能不仅要注意你旅行去到那儿的那几天的天气。
之前几天的天气可能也要稍待着注意一下，
这样可能才不会影响你整个行程当中的安排。
好，游山玩水的部分就结束了。
接下来我们会专注到贵州美食安利的部分。
就是我个人本身就非常喜欢吃这种酸酸辣辣的东西。
在北京有一些这种所谓的贵州火锅店，
在贵州米粉店、贵州炒菜店，
其实都还挺符合我个人的口味的。
但是来了贵州之后，
我发现其实贵州当地真的要好吃太多了，
而且食物的种类是非常丰富的，
各种各样的食物的味道也没有一味的，
就是追求酸辣有各种各样的选择。
那我下面就非常快速简单的罗列一些，
我觉得很好吃的东西基本上都是在安顺的。
第一名我想推荐的就是一家。
灌汤猪脚店里面的烧焦牛肉，
这家店叫做囤滋味。
它家的招牌就是灌汤猪脚，
就是把炸过之后的猪脚在酸汤里面煮。
我个人是不太喜欢这种炸过之后猪脚的口感的。
我可能更喜欢那种纯粹的，
就是嘣嘣很有胶原感的那种猪脚的口感。
如果你在北京的话，
我还是很推荐北京的一家做酸汤猪脚的店，
在团建湖山里附近叫做小街猪脚，
真的非常好吃。
我甚至觉得比我在贵州吃到的猪脚还要更好吃，
更符合我的口味一些。
但是这家灌汤猪脚店的烧焦牛肉真的太香了。
就是我也是来了之后才发现，
其实烧焦也是贵州菜里经常用到的一个调味和烹饪方法，
而且贵州本地的牛肉品质真的都很不错，
或者说当地的餐厅很知道要怎么处理这些牛肉。
就是不管是当地的正经的这种炒菜的餐厅，
还是烧烤店还是路边的粉店，
牛肉的口感就是非常的合适，
就是该嫩的时候它是嫩的，
该筋道的地方它是筋道的，
该软烂的时候它是软烂的，
而且调味也非常的balanced，很平衡。
然后这家店的烧焦牛肉呢，
就是你吃起来会觉得它很有滋味，
但是不会特别的刺激，
然后你去单吃拿它配米饭，
然后吃完了之后用它的料煮火锅都是非常好吃的。
然后我有时候会觉得现在很多热门的餐厅吧，
和过去几年的当代艺术其实有点异曲同工。
就是你只要把一个东西的尺寸做得很大，
造型颜色搞得很夸张，
就总会有人或者有美术馆愿意为它买单的。
就大家好像越来越喜欢越来越习惯这种直接的刺激和冲击，
就好像其实传统的川菜其实是有很多味道清淡用料比较简单的菜的，
但是现在慢慢慢慢的就算是很多那种很传统的大牌的川菜馆，
也已经很少有人在做这些菜了，
就是大众的口味变了，
大家更喜欢那种口味更刺激更浓重的菜品，
我觉得会有一点可惜吧，
但这确实就是一个时代的变化，
好像有车远了。
然后安顺呢，除了我说的这个什么烧焦啊，
之外还有很多很多种的火锅，
本人是一个非常喜欢吃火锅的人，
就是一周七天我都吃火锅也是没问题的那种。
但是安顺就是一周七天，
我觉得你去吃火锅可能可以吃到完全不同的种类的火锅。
它有什么豆米火锅，辣子鸡火锅，
然后豆米火锅里面有红汤、白汤等等各种各样的选择。
而且大部分的火锅店的蔬菜都是无限量自助的，
而且这些菜都非常非常的新鲜，
那个新鲜程度就是这个菜叶子拿到你手里，
每一片都是非常水嫩，很汁冷着的。
怎么形容呢？
就是这个蔬菜的精神面貌很好的感觉。
就我觉得现在很多北京的菜市场和生鲜市场里面的蔬菜，
确实精神面貌也还是不错了。
但是确实你在当地看到这些蔬菜的时候，
你就觉得对比下来真的很不一样。
然后这次吃到的所有所有的火锅里面，
我自己最推荐的就是这个红酸汤的豆米火锅。
尤其是它的豆米火锅的汤煮到后面，
它会慢慢的变得有一些浓稠。
这个时候你咬一口它的那个汤拌上米饭，
实在就是鲜品太好吃了。
然后我印象里面其实北京已经有挺多家这种豆米火锅的。
然后从口味上来说，尤其是汤底的口味上来说，
我觉得谎言程度还是可以的，
就味道本身没有差别那么大。
但是可能在蔬菜啊，还有肉啊，
这些食材的选择上面确实可能没有当地的那么新鲜。
如果你在北京可以去尝试一下豆米火锅，
可能也不太会让你感到失望。
但是相比之下呢，
我在安顺迟到的这种烙锅和北京我迟到的几家店的差距就很大了。
我在安顺迟到的这些烙锅其实大部分点的菜，
不管是素菜还是肉菜，
都是在后厨会稍微炒一下处理一下，
然后再拌上来的，
所以它本身就带着一点底味和锅气。
这个烙锅本身我感觉可能也是起到一个加热的作用吧，
或者你可以把一些肉烤的脆脆焦焦的，
如果你喜欢的话。
但是我在北京大概是吃过两三家这种烙锅店吧。
对我来说它们就是一种另外形式的自助烤肉，
而且蘸料的底料都非常非常的咸，
我觉得就是区别还挺大的。
所以我觉得如果你去安顺或者是贵州的其他地方遇到烙锅，
还是可以尝试一下的，
它可能跟你在其他的大城市里面吃到的味道是不太一样的。
除了正餐之外呢，比较突破我认知的其实就是安顺当地还有很多甜品和小吃还有水果。
比如说当地用那种破苏包，
它就是包子皮是很多很多层很宣户的那种馒头一样的质感。
有点像叉烧包，
然后里面的馅呢是红豆沙配咸肉馅。
就听起来有点难接受，
但是当你勾起勇气吃一口的时候你就会觉得真香啊。
除此之外还有它的一个甜点叫做冰浆，
我觉得它可能就是类似于沙冰凉凉的饮料。
然后当地你一般可以选择很多的口味，
比如说什么黄瓜、抹茶、芒果之类的。
我觉得它可能跟平时的沙冰对比起来会口感更加细腻一些。
然后当地的这个冰浆有一个特色是会在里面加糯米，
所以你能嚼到这种一粒一粒的软软糯糯的东西，
就还是让它的口感会变得丰富一些。
然后整体的调味我觉得可能也比较偏向于自然水果的味道，
还是非常非常不错的。
然后除此之外其实贵州当地还有很多特色的水果，
然后我去的时候是6月初嘛，
6月初其实还并没有到这个贵州水果的旺季。
像安顺当地比较有名的是他们的风堂礼，
据说是礼子界的爱马士。
AI是这样介绍他的，
他说风堂礼最大的特点就是果肉极其的清脆脱骨，
而且甜度爆表，
吃起来还自带一种浓郁的天然蜂蜜香气，
而且完全没有普通礼子的酸涩感。
他的最佳赏味器也很短，
大概是在6月中下旬到7月上旬。
我这次虽然虽然在路边看到了很多卖礼子的，
但是应该都不是真正正宗的风堂礼，
还是有一些酸涩的感觉，
如果会在6月中下旬还有7月上旬去贵州的朋友，
可以买一些来尝尝看看是不是真的像AI描述的那样，
那么的甜美，很好吃的感觉。
但是我在路边水果店就随便买了一些当地比较印记的水果，
然后这些可能在网上也没有那么多的介绍。
有一种就是像皮派一样小小的黄黄的香蕉，
还有一个那种很小很丑很脆的桃子都很好吃。
我感觉当地的这些水果就是卖相真的很一般，
但是都保持了各种各样水果自己本身的那种原汁原味，
就是桃子有桃子味，香蕉有香蕉味。
我感觉这个在现在的水果界来说已经非常非常难得了，
就是在北京我吃到了很多水果比如说桃子，
它可能很大看起来很好看很脆，
但是就是完全没有味道，就很空洞的感觉。
那除了上面说的所有的这些吃的之外，当地还有很多好喝的，
比如说本地有一个奶制品品牌叫做好一多，
它会出产抹茶酸奶，
还有一款很神奇的胡萝卜味的调味奶都很好喝，
尤其是因为现在贵州其实是全世界很大的一个抹茶的产地，
所以你能在当地喝到很多很新鲜的抹茶的饮料，
然后安顺本地也有一个奶茶店叫做宫顶茶，
这个应该在其他地方都是没有的，
它的有一款叫做贵州抹茶巴勒真的非常的好喝，
然后如果你去到贵阳的话，贵阳有一家也是本地的奶茶店叫做去茶山，
有一款饮料叫做赤梨莫里茶，
赤梨也是贵阳本地的一种水果，
它可能本身会有一点酸酸色色的味道，
就并不是每个人都可以接受的，
但是我本身就比较喜欢喝酸的东西，
所以我觉得这个赤梨莫里茶，
就算是不加糖也很好喝，
尤其是在夏天冰冰凉凉的情况下，
然后如果你不确定自己到底能不能接受赤梨的这个味道呢，
你去店里面在点这个茶之前，
它可以提供一些免费的试喝，
我觉得这个店可能真的很想去突出宣传贵州的这种特产吧，
所以也是打出一种旗号，
就是说请给贵州的赤梨一个机会，
你可以尝一尝，
如果你不喜欢的话，
我们可以帮你换掉，
然后除此之外呢，
贵阳的咖啡店其实也有很多很好的，
比如说很有名的这个乔治队长，
他们现在应该已经做大做强了，
在贵州有很多很多的店，
然后甚至他们现在有网店，
在网上你可以买到他的咖啡豆，
我自己平时手冲的咖啡豆其实都是在他们家买的，
我觉得浅红的和几浅红的咖啡豆味道都还是不错的，
而且有一些性价比还不错的选择，
反正我觉得贵州的美食真的太多了，
但是用波克讲美食，
我只能说我的语言和表达能力还是太平极，太有限了，
之后我应该会在小红书发一些图文或者是视频，
感兴趣的朋友也可以在收音组里面找到我的账号链接，
也欢迎大家关注。
那这些节目最后的最后呢，
我想和大家分享几个在贵州我觉得很温暖的瞬间，
这些瞬间都是来自于当地的一些大姐。
有一天我在安顺的超市逛到了这个辣椒还有调味料的区域，
就是面前有各种各样的辣椒粉，
然后有七八种老干妈的类似，
我就占了很大一片地方，
然后我就很想买一点带回家，
我觉得当地买的辣椒一定比我在网上买的好，
但是我不知道买哪个，
然后当时应该是我去的比较晚，
这个超市还有5分钟10分钟就关门了，
然后调料区的大姐其实这个时候已经换上了日常的衣服，
已经没有穿工作服了，
她就突然走过来给我卡卡一栋讲解说，
这个可以做蘸水，这个是个炒菜，这个是个做烧烤。
我当时觉得，人家下班之前还愿意给我这样细心的讲解，
就真好啊，
然后买完这些调味料之后呢，
我又去了旁边的零食区，
想着说第二天要去野蛮买一些那种能量的补给，
我看到了有一个牛肉干，我拿着叫走，
结果又被另一个服务员大姐叫住说，
这个不好吃，你得买安顺本地的，
这个更便宜，更好吃，量还大，
然后我就主打一个听劝，
结果真的非常的好吃，
第二天不光是我，
然后还要一起去攀岩的遇到的其他的朋友，
也是卡卡一桶吃，觉得很不错。
这牛肉干的牌子叫做高原送，
就是送哥的送，
他的香辣手撕牛肉干真的非常的好，
然后后来我在淘宝，
走到了他有卖的，
然后就买了一些到北京的家里，
大家可以试试看。
其实我就是经常在贵州会感觉到，
遇到的大姐和阿姨都很真诚很热心，
就比如说我在火车上要泡泡面，
然后路过的成务员阿姨就会提醒我说，
那边的热水可能需要放一下，
一开始那一段不会特别特别的热，
然后又比如我在机场吃粉，
然后服务员阿姨就会提醒我说，
我想坐的那个位置好像空调的风很大，
你可以坐去另外一边，
那一边都可以坐更舒服之类之类的。
出门在外能遇到这种小小的非常适宜的关心，
还是会让人觉得挺温暖的。
那本期节目我们就先聊到这里，
如果你喜欢本期节目，
就欢迎订阅点赞分享，
如果你有任何想要交流的，
就欢迎在评论区留言，
我的旅行了照片攻略Vlog，
都会发布在我的小红书账号，
账号名是默默女士下班了，
账号链接可以在shownotes里面找到，
欢迎关注，
祝你天天开心，
留人种得旅途愉快，
我们下期就试地久天差。